un paso pequeño pero significativo 20
niños ucranianos con cáncer han sido
ingresados en hospitales franceses en su
país al menos 150 centros hospitalarios
han sido destruidos por los bombardeos
rusos lo que hace imposible continuar
con su tratamiento algunos salieron en
el momento justo y les acababa de salir
del hospital cuando fue destruido para
las familias de los niños afectados es
un alivio muy contenta de que sea
tratada acá porque en ucrania ahora no
hay ningún lugar donde pueda recibir
tratamientos y
lo más importante para nosotros es que
nuestra hija reciba atención teníamos
esta posibilidad y dijimos que si
todos los que trabajan en el hospital
están contentos por poder aportar su
granito de arena
el cáncer es la primera causa de
enfermedad en los niños mayores de un
año es una enfermedad extremadamente
grave ya estos niños que sufren tanto la
guerra como su tratamiento es muy
importante que los cuidemos
y sueño en la actualidad unos 1500 niños
de ucrania padecen cáncer y como muchos
de ellos no tienen donde ir
francia podría acoger a muchos en las
próximas semanas